You are listening to radio
lab radio from W N Y s t e
n n p r I am Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and
today my name is Peter Lang Stanton.
My name is Nick Faraga. Well we're gonna
get a story from two reporters. Um,
I'm a freelance film
maker, freelance reporter,
writer slash radio
producer to many slashes.
It's a story that goes
back about 70 years. It's,
it all feels like unreal in some way,
but there's something about
this story that just is,
you hear it and you can't help but think
about now. Yeah. Should we start with,
with air currents or like go with,
I mean I I want to start with can we go
to Thermopolis Wyoming cause that was,
that was one of the first really well
documented landings. Thermopolis, Wyoming.
Well it's the first week of December, 1944
this is Ross Cohen. He's a
historian and he wrote a book.
That's pretty much the definitive account
of the story you're about to hear.
Any health Thermopolis,
Wyoming, December, 1944
and there are three liners at a
place called the highline coal mine,
which is outside of Dimopoulos. They
step outside the mine one evening.
It's just about dusk and just
as they step out of the mind,
they hear this whistling sound over
their heads and then a moment later,
yes,
a tremendous explosion and they see this
rising cloud of dust about a mile away
across the valley. They turn and look.
It's dusk and so in the fading twilight,
they can't be sure exactly
what they're looking at,
but above them there's sort
of this fluttering white
circle just floating there.
They made sense of it by thinking it was
parachutists. They watched this parachute
as it's drifting away from them.
They get in their car and they chase
after it until eventually they lose sight
of it in the dark.
Yes. Right around that same time,
about 500 miles away in Colorado, a boy
and his dad are working in the barn.
When they hear an explosion, they
run outside and in their yard.
There's just this smoldering crater
in Wyoming, a nine year old
boy playing in his front yard.
Here's an explosion all throughout
the winter of 1944 in Burwell,
Nebraska. Strange parachute thing.
Native residents here, a loud explosion,
just start appearing in
the skies all over America, Napa,
California, lame deer, Montana,
20 or so miles from downtown Detroit
over farms, Nogales, Arizona,
slipping behind hills, Rigby, Idaho.
Everybody who sees these things,
all of them have different explanations
for what they think they're witnessing.
They think it's a plane
crash, an oil tank exploding.
The U s military sends out an APB
to local police station saying,
we need information. What are these
things? Try again. Testing, testing. Ah,
there we go. Okay. Hello. Hello.
Enter Sheriff Warren. Hide. Uh,
my name is Marianne hide.
Warren hide actually died in 1989
so I'm the oldest son of sheriff.
We talked to his son. He had
a presence about him, the to,
he kind of commanded a room. Sheriff
Hyde was a big guy, black wavy hair,
brought out the shoulder,
narrow at the hips that's in gun on
his hip and one day he's at his office,
north of Salt Lake City. When his
phone rings, from what I understand,
a dry farmer called, he said,
there's this strange
contraption in my field,
some kind of balloon parachute
looking thing floating around.
So he jumped in the car and uh,
went hell bent for leather
out into the Blue Creek area.
There's this crazy story where he rushes
out to this farm to investigate hops
out of his car,
rips off his belt with this 38 pistol
because a man can run with a 38 pistol on
his waist and took off after the bloom.
Here's what he sees in that field. It was,
I mean if you look at a picture of
this thing, it's this huge globe,
30 feet in diameter. Oh Wow. Paper, White,
and then coming down from this globe
or these thick 40 foot ropes and at the
bottom attached to it is a,
is a heavy metal chandelier
with bombs hanging off the
bottom and sheriff hide.
He sees this thing,
runs out into the field,
grabs onto the ropes to maybe tie it down,
but just as he grabbed
that Augusta wind comes by,
lifts him up off the ground like he was
papered off and so he's dangling from
the ropes of this thing.
The balloon is above him,
the explosives or are below him and it
takes him across this canyon and he's
holding on just dangling from it,
still trying to wrangle it like,
like some bucking Bronco. He lands again,
he tries to tie it to a
juniper Bush or something,
but the wind catches it again and goes
back over the canyon back to the first
time, back to the first sign they
started to float around the field.
He kept wrestling this
balloon for a long time.
He's nauseous from being
spun around on this balloon.
His Vision's getting blurry, his
hands are becoming raw from the rope,
but he feels this like sense of duty.
He knew that the government wanted
one of these balloons, his territory.
So he's got to take it down. That's ride.
He finally lets himself free
fall so he can grab it again.
So his weight will jerk
the balloon to the ground.
Then finally the balloon came down in
kind of a little ravine where a sage rush
were growing and a root had been
exposed on the side of the ravine from a
sagebrush and he hooks his
arm around this, this route.
Then he was able to hold the balloon
without being carried into the air here.
So we actually captured the thing. Yeah.
J Edgar Hoover wrote him a
personal letter of thanks.
They ended up shipping all of the evidence
off to the Aberdeen Military Research
Facility where they had gathered all
this different evidence from all over the
country. And after looking
at this stuff for awhile,
they were able to tell that apparently
this bomb was not of any particular, uh,
American make and match known
characteristics of Japanese bombs.
So it's Japanese. Yeah,
but it's impossible to send a balloon
across the Pacific Ocean at this point.
I mean, it's never,
never been done. I mean,
it's basically an intercontinental
ballistic missile,
so they're trying to figure
out where it's coming from.
They thought maybe they were
being launched from submarines.
Maybe they were coming from beaches
in North America from saboteurs.
There was even speculation at one
point that maybe they were coming from
Japanese internment
camps in North America.
Then two days before
Christmas, 1944 in Alaska,
a native Alaskan trapper tracks went down
and it has two sandbags still attached
to the bottom most ring,
and that turns out to be the key to
the mystery sand. Yeah. Well, just Sam,
there's a lot in there. My
name is Elisa, Berks Lynne,
and I am a forensic geologist.
We call the Balisa to help
us understand this next part.
What happened was the sand from the
balloons was sent to Washington DC to some
scientists at the US Geological Survey.
Right away they discover
that there's no coral,
so you don't have finding no coral.
You know you're talking cold water.
Now they look at the
diatoms marine [inaudible]
microscopic fossils mollusks by
compiling all of these different
characteristics, put that all together.
Where would you find these diatoms,
these minerals that you wouldn't find
coral though all those different pieces of
information all together,
the geologists are able to determine that
there are two or perhaps three beaches
in the world that fit all
of these qualifications
where they believe this sand
could have come from and all of which
are on the east coast of Honshu,
the largest of Japan's four main islands.
You can get that kind of specific
from sand. Yup. That kind of specific.
Pretty incredible. All right,
so they came all the way from these
particular beaches on the coast of Japan?
Yeah. Six thousands of miles
across the Pacific Ocean.
And why would the Japanese choose to
s to deliver bomb payloads by balloon?
But it's a strange choice in
particularly after Pearl Harbor, they,
we know where, you know
they can do planes. Farragut
planes. Yeah. Why balloons?
Well,
I would can be told history in the making.
It grew directly out
of the Doolittle raid.
Back in April of 1942 United States Navy
aircraft carrier haunted deems westward
across,
represented Jimmy Doolittle and his
Raiders took off from an aircraft carrier
deep in the Western Pacific and dropped
bombs on Tokyo and Yokohama and Kobe and
a number of other cities across Japan.
Great as the fries raid in the
history of aerial warfare. Now,
they didn't do a lot of damage physically,
but it was such a shock to the Japanese
to think that their
homeland could be invaded,
that these planes could actually
fly over the imperial palace.
The home of the emperor and do little
went over the palace head is you realize
that? Yeah. He went all the way downtown
in Tokyo. Oh yeah. Right over the city.
And so immediately after the
Doolittle raid, an order went out,
it was just find a way to bomb America.
[inaudible]
no, Japan's navy is stretched so
thin at this point in the war.
There's no way they can pull off
something like the do little rate.
They didn't have aircraft carriers that
could get their planes close enough to
the US mainland. But what they did have
was the wind. Today we
call this the jet stream.
That name didn't come along until
after the war. At that point,
we barely knew about the jet stream,
but prior to and during the war,
the Japanese did a extensive
research into these wins. Okay, so
in 1924 there's this meteorologist named
Watson Burrow Ichi and he goes to the
top of a mountain and he releases a bunch
of these little paper weather balloons
and he discovers
that at about 30,000 feet up,
there's this river of fast moving air
speeds up to 175 miles an hour carrying
anything in its Miss Pollen, insects all
the way to North America within days.
And after the Doolittle raid,
they thought maybe if we were to release
a bunch of balloons in just the right
place at just the right time,
maybe this jet stream of air could push
these balloons across the Pacific Ocean.
[inaudible] so this is Tesco Tanaka.
She was interviewed in this independent
documentary called on-paper wings
[inaudible] in 1944 she says she was a
teenager when the Japanese military came
to her school and basically
turned it into a factory.
[inaudible].
She and hundreds of other schoolchildren
were conscripted to begin making this
special kind of paper out of
mulberry wood called [inaudible].
Was she handmade? This traditional paper?
This is my host Sheena, who now works
at the new Burrito Institute in Japan.
Huge amount of paper was required.
My host says that girls would work
12 hour days making thousands,
tens of thousands of these
sheets and gluing them together.
Why didn't they have
adults in the factories?
They were all fighting the war or what
young girls have either been
good for that boat. [inaudible]
the girls had a certain
dexterity for the name Burmese,
Nimble fingers.
I think I read that song somewhere
and after they finished producing the
balloons and after the balloons
were strapped with bombs,
they were shipped off to
those beaches and just let go.
People from the Japanese side watching
them take off said they like huge
jellyfish swimming
through a pale blue sky.
These perfectly silent vehicles.
The only sound was the rustling
of the paper as they took off
[inaudible].
How many were launched from November,
1944 to April, 1945 they
launched 9,000 balloons. Wow.
[inaudible] no,
the engineers in Japan who designed
this faced a very serious problem.
Once they got the balloons up into the
jet stream and they were cruising along
there floating at speeds from
50 to a hundred miles an hour,
but every night temperatures are going
to fall to minus 40 centigrade and the
fixtures volume of hydrogen inside
that envelope is going to contract.
The balloon is going to lose altitude
drop out of the jet stream and down into
the ocean altogether. So to
solve this says Ross, they,
what they did was this, they took 32
sandbags, hung them on the balloon,
and then connected those sandbags to an
altimeter set to a preset and minimum
such as 30,000 feet in the nighttime.
When the balloon loses altitude,
the altimeter will engage,
trigger a fuse,
which cuts off one of those sandbags
and drops it into the ocean.
And now the vehicle will reascend back
into the jet stream because it's lighter
because it's lighter. So these balloons,
they're riding the jet stream and then
every night they start to descend.
But then off would go a sandbag and
they'd go back up and whenever they cooled
off enough to drop, same
thing drop, then rise, drop,
then rise over and over 32 times
until every sandbag was gone.
Once all the sandbags have been dropped,
now you have only the bombs remaining
and the bombs are held in place with the
exact same mechanism as the sandbags.
And now by the very same system,
the bombs are the last to go.
And presumably the balloon is
now somewhere over North America.
Okay, I see. So it's a sandbag countdown,
30209208432 one I hope I'm in Oregon.
Right.
And when it was in Oregon or wherever
the idea was that it would drop its last
bomb Floataway in basically self destruct.
They, I guess figured it would be,
it would be more terrifying to have bombs
raining down silently from above with
no calling card at all. Then
with a Japanese calling card.
Damn, that was the last sandbag is la.
Now only the central payload is left.
This is audio from a declassified navy
instructional video made about these
balloon bombs in 1945
in the advanced. One of units is found.
Do these two things to render at
Armas explains to soldiers how to,
what to do if they find one of these
bombs and how to diffuse the bomb. No,
but I think the most interesting thing
about the video is this text that's
written in huge block letters. Right
at the bottom of the screen it says,
do not aid the enemy by publishing
or broadcasting or discussing
information.
Information can be a powerful tool.
It can be a powerful tool for
good and a powerful tool for evil.
This is professor Mike Sweeney and I'm
a historian. I've wartime censorship.
And he says that immediately
after those first balloons landed,
there are a few stories that appear in
the local newspapers in the far west,
stories about a Japanese attack on
the mainland of United States time.
And Newsweek even picked it up
saying, we're not sure what these are,
but you know, are these Japanese
spies coming in on these balloons?
Is this a large scale attack?
What is going on? And then
very shortly thereafter, just three days
after those time and Newsweek articles,
the office of censorship
initiated a press blackout.
This blackout on news.
They sent out memos and telegraphs
to all the major wire services,
the UPD P in the ins saying,
keep any news of these Japanese balloons
off the wires and out-of-print any
stories about these bombs will have to
be approved by the appropriate authority
or the U s army if you wish to
publish or broadcast news about them.
And why would they want
to keep this secret?
So the government's ideas about why
balloon bombs should be censored.
In particular, the army's ideas
were number one, to avoid panic.
These things are instruments
of terror, right?
You can't be afraid of
something you don't know exists.
Number two is a avoid helping Japan.
It was thought then that if we printed
exact coordinates of particular bomb
landings that this would help Japan
better target the bombs and what are the
reporters think about this. They grumbled
some times, but they complied. Really?
Yup. Everyone in the news industry was
as patriotic as the rest of the country.
That is the vast majority of
journalists supported the war.
And of course if you screwed up and you
sent out a story that got American lives
killed, you can be prosecuted under
the espionage act. Furthermore,
can you imagine what your listeners
would do if you're the radio station
identified as killing a
hundred American sailors?
Yeah.
So the newspapers and radio
stations kept their mouth shut,
which meant that most Americans
never even heard this was happening.
And more importantly,
the Japanese weren't really hearing
about whether their bombs made it or not.
So they probably concluded that it
was basically a failed experiment,
which largely it was of the 9,000
released virtually none cause any damage.
And certainly not any terror
except
for this one balloon that's coming up.
Hi, this is well calling
from Northumberland England.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred peace known foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information about
slow@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
We continue now with our story
from reporters, Peter Link,
Stanton and Nick Farago about, uh,
the 9,000 or so balloon bombs Japan sent
to America in 1944 and 45 that rained
down on American soil and created nothing.
Really nothing happened,
no damage, no terror,
nothing. But then we get to this tiny
little town called [inaudible]. To me,
there's no place like old Bli.
Bli Is this sleepy little
logging town at the base of your
Heart Mountain in South Central
Oregon. A lot of pretty scenery.
And Cora Connor, who you just
heard was born and raised there.
You know everybody in here,
they're just like a big family
out there in the forties,
when Cora was a young girl, there were
about 700 people living there. Yeah.
But we did all kinds of fun things.
We had a fish fry up at dog lake,
huge cat fish fry up there. The
whole town stayed all night,
went back home the next
day, and the winner,
the canals would freeze over and we to
have bonfire in ice skating parties and
it was a fun place to
live. Tell me about, um,
uh, the morning. Was it a Sunday? Let's
see what happened. I am trying to think.
Saturday, I think May 5th
that's all I can remember. Yup.
That was May 5th, May 5th, 1945.
I thought it was a beautiful day.
The Sun was shining bright
and the Reverend Archie
Mitchell and his wife Elsie,
who was five months pregnant with her
first child doing very well at Sunday
school. I went to church
occasionally up there.
They took their Sunday school
class out for a picnic.
There were five children
that went along on that trip,
ages 11 to 14 and one of the
kids, we called him Dickey.
He had a crush on my sister who has
little younger than me and they wanted her
to come on this picnic.
So Nate came by and stopped the pastor
and his wife stopped and the kids all
piled out. They stopped when they
went up. Yeah, trying to talk,
convinced my mom to let my sister
go or both of us or whatever,
but mom didn't want us to go because
Saturday was our Chore Day and my day at
work, the switchboard, which
usually made me pretty angry,
but that was my job and
she said, no, I'm no way.
Well,
my sister didn't really want to go
because she really wasn't encouraging this
relationship too much. Yeah, Dickey. Yeah.
No.
So Archie and LZ and the five kids get
back into the car and they drove up to
Gearhart mountain a couple
of miles up a logging road.
They passed some forest
service guys working
on the road.
They go a little further to where the
road comes near Creek and Archie pulled
the car around and parked the kids,
jumped out of the car and started
running down toward the creek.
Elsie who was pregnant, as I mentioned,
and she was feeling a bit car sick.
She jumped out to get some fresh
air and to chase after the kids.
While Archie went around to the trunk of
the car to get up the fishing poles and
the picnic baskets, et cetera.
One of the children saw
something on the ground,
a large canvas, white,
gray balloon of some kind
spread out on the ground,
called her the other
children to come have a look.
The children and Elsie apparently gathered
in a tight circle around the balloon.
Archie later reported that while he was
getting the picnic basket out of the
trunk, his wife called to him, honey,
come look at what we found.
He turned and just took a few steps
toward them and at that moment we'll never
know exactly what happened,
but apparently one of the children
reached down to pick up the device.
The bomb detonated.
Yeah.
All five children and Elsie
Mitchell were killed instantly.
The forest service guys down the road,
we're close enough to hear the blast.
They come running when they hear the
explosion and they see Archie Mitchell has
run to the site and his wife's clothes
were ablaze and Archie was kneeling over
his prostrate wife beating up
the fire with his bare hands.
[inaudible]
on our last day in GLI, we went to
visit the site where the bomb went off
in the middle of nowhere.
It's just a chain,
just a little chink fenced off area.
It's a little pen and there
are these tall pine trees.
It's just huge. Cuts in the tree is a
shrapnel cuts in the tree. Yeah. Yeah.
They still, it hasn't a,
has not healed
eerie place.
Of course. I didn't know since
dwindle what was going on?
This is Cora Connor again.
At the time she was at her job watching
the switchboard when the guy that was
working up there for the forest service
in Russian and to the telephone office
and I mean he was scared, pure white
and scared and I thought, my God,
what's on what's happening?
And he came in and made
the call to Lakefield,
the naval base in lake view and about
a half an hour later this, you know,
big imposing military guy comes in.
He was on metals and all and
he's full uniform, you know,
and he must have made it, it seemed like
in a blink of an eye. And I thought,
my God, what has happened? And
then when he talked over the phone,
I knew what was going on.
He said they'd had a bomb explode
up there with the casualties.
And then he talked to me. He said,
do you not talk to anybody about
anything that you've heard here?
Not your mother, not anybody. He says,
now you're not to leave this office.
By then I was just jelly.
I was still terrified.
He leaves and the word is is trickling
around, spreading around town.
They knew something had gone wrong and
they gathered at the phone office because
the phone office knows everything
in the whole valley. Then they knew,
I knew what was going on
and that's when it all hit.
Pretty soon there was a crowd
outside screaming and yelling at me.
And, yeah, yeah, yeah. We
know. You know what's going on.
You better come out and tell us we're
coming in there and you're going to tell
us what's happened and all
your neighbors and things like,
yeah, no, you, they're
saying and they know. Yeah.
Cause blinds is very tiny place.
I probably knew every one of them.
I was about,
you could imagine the
state I was in and uh,
Mr Passkey Dickey's father Dickey was
the boy who had a crush on Cora's sister.
I can tell you exactly how
he has dressed that day.
He had on a red and black
checkered hunting shirt and
his red hunting cat at the
time, all he knew is
that his son was missing.
He stood out there and they shook his
fist and he yelled and he scared me half
to death, threatening to come
in and all that. He says,
you know what's happening?
Let us know what's happening.
And I couldn't do anything.
I sat there all day.
Okay 16 you know, it really,
really tore me apart.
That was just in a
complete fog for days. No,
I'd never, never talked
too much about it. Nope.
Within a day or so,
the military told most of the town what
actually happened that day and then a
short time after that,
a big army truck. Well,
it was two big army trucks. They
stopped right out in front of our house.
We wondered what was going on. You
know your little town like that.
Anything different.
Everybody goes to the window
and bakers look and here come,
okay, this is awfully hard for me.
A woman and a little kid jumped
out of the back of truck.
She was Japanese. They run
their way to the, to lake,
the Japanese interment camp nearby and
she's screaming and crying and praying,
please, we need water. We
need water. It was hot.
It was really hot that day and they
were in a canvas covered truck jammed in
there and
I grabbed a picture of a bucket or
whatever was there in the kitchen,
filled it with water and
stuttered it out the door.
By that time they were throwing
rocks at that lady and her kid,
people in that town were so terribly
upset and they were throwing rocks at her
and mom would let me go and I screamed
and cried at my mother because she
wouldn't let me go. She
goes, you can't go out there.
They'll throw rocks at
you. I won't let you go.
And do they stay that pictures in my
mind and I have prayed to the Lord to
forgive the people that
were doing that and try to,
I can't accept it. There's no, nothing
could make me accept what had happened.
I thought that was the most
horrible thing in the world.
People could do a woman and child.
They had nothing to do with the bomb.
Nothing to do with the war. Nothing.
Okay.
It does. It's still hard.
How can people be that way?
Hmm.
It upset me so horribly bad,
but didn't want to talk about
it. I couldn't talk for 40 years.
[inaudible]
it's weird, like it's a kind of weird,
scary symmetry to this whole thing.
Like the Japanese military was
trying to create terror, right?
Like what they felt after too little
and so they wanted to make the situation
where like bombs were falling
silently from the sky.
We couldn't even tell where
they were coming from.
Almost like the gods were dropping them,
but we kept it quiet so nobody
panicked except by not saying anything.
At least in this one small instance,
it created exactly the situation
that the Japanese military wanted.
I mean not on the scale that they
wanted, but like in it's effect,
it's like a concentrated version of the
thing they're trying to create. Right.
That's the problem. That's not a problem.
Five is five is a sacrifice in
war. What is it? Five six people?
Yeah. There were, there were. There
were 125 million people in America then.
Hmm. I think there actually might
have been a little bit more. Yeah,
well you can see what
it would have been like.
Listen to this story. You
could see what a room like if,
if this story had been well known and
had been told from person to person.
If everybody was looking
up and wondering where the next
strange thing was coming from.
Well they wouldn't,
there might've been panic but those kids
wouldn't have talked on the balloons.
That's that's the choice cause
they would have known. Yeah. Hey,
I'm sorry to jump in here.
I just know that we don't have Ross much
longer in order to respect your time.
Um, separate. Is there any males who
worked with Nick and Peter on this,
on the story before they kick you out?
The only last question I kind of
was had on my list is I'm like,
why is it that we don't know about this?
Like I've never heard of this
before. I don't know if Robert,
if you've heard this before,
like why like why the hell
is this not a thing we know.
I think it's directly an outgrowth
of that censorship policy.
At the end of the war, the war
department destroyed all of the evidence.
They didn't want these, any
evidence of these balloons.
I'm just out there in
general circulation. Huh?
This is one of those footnotes
to the war that you know,
at the end of the war, just never people,
people forgot about something that
they didn't know about anyway. Wow.
Ross, are there any more out there?
That is a very interesting question.
It's estimated by the war department
that of the 9,000 release,
they thought that maybe seven to 10%
of the total would have survived the
transoceanic crossing and
arrived in North America.
That's 900 300 are confirmed as
having arrived in North America,
so that means there are dozens,
perhaps hundreds that arrived in North
America but were never accounted for in
the 10 or 12 years. Immediately
after the end of World War Two,
a couple dozen of these things were
found several in Oregon in 1948 when in
Alaska in 1955 one in Idaho in the
early 1960s and then the recoveries stop
where the, where they live.
Like the one in Oregon,
like if you touched them
with the blow of them.
Well, some of them were. Now
here's the fascinating part.
Last October, October
of 2014 I kid you not.
Dave was ahead of me and
he'd stopped and said,
I think I saw, I'm the bomb.
A couple of loggers.
Yeah. My name is Preston Linger.
His name's Dave Bridgeman
in Lumby, British Columbia,
who are doing some survey work.
You know, this is the middle of nowhere.
Found the remnants of a Japanese balloon
that had been on the ground for 70
years.
Definitely work in remote
areas and in general,
and we don't see much except trees
and rock. But, uh, you know, there,
there are those odd
special days where you,
where you see things that
no one else gets to see.
This happened just a few months
ago. I tell you, if you're hiking,
if you're out in the woods in the
Pacific northwest, watch where you step.